joining us now on the rich eisen show on
the mercedes-benz van phone line uh a
man who is as great as they come in the
national football league and his
pittsburgh steelers are on a nice roll
right now and they're rolling into
monday night football which i'll be
hosting the pregame and halftime show of
on westwood one radio on monday night he
is none other than pittsburgh steeler
pro bowler and all pro t.j watt how are
you tj
i'm doing really well thank you for
having me on thanks for coming on right
now how is everything with this team
right now it seems like you are on a
nice
stretch certainly compared to the
beginning of the season would you would
you agree with that assessment tj watt
yeah i would and i think uh these last
few games especially getting into the
the bye week at an even 500 was was kind
of our goal once we started out at one
three and then uh obviously being able
to get a win uh in the division was huge
this past week and
we just want to continue to take it one
week at a time and stack these wins how
would you categorize your role with this
team i know what i would call it but i'm
on the outside i wonder what you would
say on that front as an outside
linebacker in a 3-4 defense for the
pittsburgh steelers you have to be a
playmaker and uh i think that's
something that i take on with great
pride in
trying to
bring as much splash we'd like to call
it whether it's getting tackles for loss
getting sacks punching the ball out
tipping passes up in the air
interceptions anything like that i'm
trying to be a tone setter for our
defense
and that's just something i'm trying to
do each and every single play every time
i'm on the field for my defense then
what about after uh games before games
uh you know locker room stuff how would
you
categorize your role in that
sort of thing uh i'd say a very calm and
relaxed person throughout the week i go
about my business i don't really i'm not
a big rock rowdy guy throughout the week
and then it's almost like a switch is
flipped come game day um kind of turn
into a whole different uh person when it
comes to just all the work has been done
i'm going to put every single thing that
i have
um into this game and that's kind of
where the rah-rah stuff comes out and
i'll give
the pre-game speech before every game
and obviously i talk to the the outside
and inside linebackers
in a huddle before the game too so it's
kind of two totally different
um
emotions throughout the week and then
come game day is there something you
think of person you think of a moment to
flip that switch help you flip it at all
i don't know i think it might come from
just watching how my brother's played
throughout the years when it comes to jj
i think part of it is just kind of in my
dna of who i am as a person and
loving the game of football and
wanting to give every single thing that
i can to this game because
i can only play for so long and i
understand how rare it is to be in the
national football league and
i'm just so lucky to get to do this for
a living and i just want to pour
everything i have
into it not only for myself but for my
teammates and for the whole city of
pittsburgh and everybody that roots for
us how did that play into you getting
your bag that you deserved i mean the
business side that just doesn't usually
compute with me when i'm you know my
contract's up in my contract years and
things like that that i have how did
that work for you
all that stuff just kind of handles
itself if you just kind of focus on um
being the best possible player you can
be and that's kind of just the approach
that i've always taken and um obviously
it did handle itself and i have great
agents and um mr rooney wanted to get
the deal done i'm glad it was done and
i'm just super happy to be able to stay
in pittsburgh for a long time
but there's still so much work that
needs to be done and i'm i just want to
be the person that can help bring this
team um another super bowl and that's
the end goal obviously well the word was
that you handled it at the end you're
you're like the closer you're like this
is it we're done is that a true story
did you like say we're done and you know
obviously you've got great agents who
put you in a position to basically say
we're done but let's just do it yes did
that happen that's partially true it
just got to a point where there was back
and forth towards the end and the minor
details obviously anybody who's dealt
with
any types of negotiations in life that
once you get towards the end there's
always little things here and there that
you want adjusted
and uh towards the end i just said hey
these these uh this organization mr
rooney have showed such great faith in
me and wanting to keep me here let's
just i'm so sick and sick and tired of
going back and forth back and forth they
have a great deal on the table and let's
just accept it and move on and i wanted
to get to work more than anything
because obviously i wasn't doing um
training camp i wasn't taking part in
that so i just wanted to get on the
field as quickly as possible and i felt
the deal was fair for both sides tj watt
here uh prior to monday night football
bears and steelers to close out week
nine right here on the rich eisen show
how good is naji harris man i i i look
at him and i think he is uh as valuable
as they come on your team tj
um what's it what's it like to see him
up close and personal maybe practice
against him we spoke to your teammate
cameron hayward earlier this week he
says he doesn't like it he didn't like
it one bit during the
training camp season at all
that's the nice thing that i missed i
didn't have to go up against them but i
was able to see from afar the right all
the one-handed catches and just uh you
know in college you always see the
running backs that no matter where you
are in the football field they always
finish their run through the end zone
and
you always think that's kind of a little
extra in doing too much but a guy like
that he just really wanted to get his
conditioning in and
no matter where we were on the field
over at heinz field during training camp
the number one thing always stuck out to
me was he would run the ball into the
end zone every single rep that he had
and that was just one of those things
that stuck out as to what kind of person
he is
um the type of
preparation he's going to put into being
a great player and nothing's really
surprised me as far as the success that
he's had and uh he's also a big guy
tough to get down i'm glad he's on our
team yeah it also looks like um he gives
you a little bit more rest right and he
keeps ben more upright ben is you know
he he keeps ben a little bit more uh
untouched clean for a guy who's pushing
forward that's got to mean a lot
in my estimate they always say the best
defense to spend a lot of time on the
bench and anytime you got naji harris
i'm in the backfield for your team
you're going to spend a lot of time on
the bench just because he can move the
chain so many different ways uh whether
it's in the pass game or like you say
picking up passport or obviously rushing
on the ground as well a couple more
things i want to ask you tj watt here
prior to monday night football uh on the
rich eisen show um i loved your coach's
response to the rumor or the fact that
he was on the usc wish list i just loved
what mike tomlin was saying never say
never but never the whole business about
there's not enough of a booster check
large enough for me how did that how did
that hit you t.j watt the rest of your
teammates all right i've heard his
analogies in the way that he speaks uh
for the past five years now and the
number one thing that i've always
admired about coach tomlin is his
transparency um without with all of his
players and obviously with the media too
like you guys saw
well that's why guys gravitate to him
and his coaching style
and uh he's just a guy that i'm just so
lucky to play for and privileged to play
for here in pittsburgh and um that who
you guys seeing to me is exactly who he
is in the meeting room and out of the
meeting i'm just an overall great guy
how has he made you a better player
for instance you got one good one for me
on that he knows how to motivate each
and every guy individually that's also
one of his great assets is what
motivates me might not motivate uh the
next guy and um he knows how to how to
pick how to pick at me if i played a
certain way a week before he knows
exactly what to say
or to say someone else is playing this
much better they play the run a little
better just little slight jabs at me
come on what gets me going come on what
do you mean give me an example of that
what do you say tj really i'll just say
like uh stolen clothes playing the run
better this week uh
would be something to take note of for
our guys to look at just something like
that where it'll be like oh okay i i
don't know if he's talking to me but i
think he's talking to me one of those
things
which is what what which is what can
motivate me but um
if it's someone else he has a whole
different tactic that i probably don't
even know about because it doesn't
register with me but that's just one of
his strengths is motivating each and
every guy and knowing how to do it um
it's pretty tough at this level when you
have guys coming from all different
backgrounds all right tj what i need i
need full disclosure not like you
haven't you've been uh avoiding any of
my questions up to this point but i feel
the need to wind up this pitch with i
need an honest answer from you on this
question tj1 okay i know it's coming
hold on a second i i asked uh cameron
hayward earlier this week i don't know
if this is what you're thinking about
but cameron hayward i heard earlier this
week he told us that you are a very
confident man clearly very confident man
that you believe that if you could get
in like the i guess pittsburgh hot tub
time machine go back to college you
could quarterback a team to a national
championship is that true tj this is
misquoted so badly okay this all started
he was correct and this started with
if we were to go back to high school
right now right as we are right now
27 years old outside linebacker
pittsburgh experience if i go back to
high school
and i played quarterback for my team
and i could play defense
would i take the team the state title
and i said yes 100
and then he said could you do it in
texas and i said yes i feel like i could
and then i got to a point where i'm
obviously very confident person and i
said i could probably go this was not a
power five conference i said i could go
to a non-power five conference at
quarterback and probably win one game
and he blew this up into saying that i
would take a politicized conference for
a national championship i don't know
if he's got beef with me but i'll figure
it out with him oh okay tomorrow in the
locker room but no that i said i could
i go to a non-power five conference
and hand the ball off and run rpos or
whatever i had to do because i feel like
i could win one game okay
as the current version of tj watt right
like you're you're yeah currently
yourself play defense
oh and you could play deep well i mean
okay that makes sense but so he made it
seem like you could just go back and
like you could go back in time and you
can quarterback oklahoma to a
championship right now like literally i
think yeah i put it out there i'm here
to say i cannot do that but i i had the
confidence enough to think that i could
do that too maybe i'll i'll take that
but i don't think i could do that you
watts are very confident people
tj you know i mean i've i've been around
your brother and now talking to you
you're very confident people you know i
think that you could pretty much apply
yourself and i believe that you think
that at least i did i think you have to
i mean
it you know having confidence is the
biggest thing that is the realization
for you that you belong um that's kind
of been the biggest thing for me in the
nfl is
the first couple years you're kind of
just trying to prove to yourself that
you belong
and then once you kind of kind of
realize that everybody's noticing you
get that whole second level of
confidence that hey i can do this and i
can do this at an elite level and that's
kind of when you tap into um
your true potential and i truly think
that the sky's the limit for not only
myself but for this team
and i'm just just like i said i'm just
just getting started
you have to be confident to get to where
you truly want to get to so you you
you've you are you guys talking super
bowl
for this year like does that stuff get
spoken or you're the beginning of your
season has just
kind of slowed your role a little bit on
that front oh yeah i mean it's nothing
that we openly talk about i think every
single team in the national football
league should be thinking super bowl but
it's just one of those things that like
i said at the beginning of this is we
need to take it one game at a time right
last one for you i i my my kids wouldn't
let me back in the house if i didn't ask
this uh are you is ultimate tag coming
back or what my kids friggin loved
that show honestly that was nice it was
a great experience it was a lot of fun
to do
with both of my brothers um obviously it
was it was gaining a lot of perspective
for being in front of a teleprompter for
myself i know
um very tough man i got a lot of respect
for people that are good at that because
it's not as easy as it looks okay honest
you when all the cameras are on but uh i
don't know i i know covered kind of
probably messed it up but i don't think
there's talks of it at all at the moment
we got to do it so my kids loved it and
then of course you know
jj just needs to be able to just scream
out it's time to play some tag to
somebody he must be missing that you
know big time
you know he's probably annoying the heck
out of his wife just screaming around
the house
hey tj thanks for the time good luck
monday let's do this more often i really
appreciate you your game and so much
more thanks for it appreciate it
no problem thanks for having me on take
care you bet that's tj watt getting
ready for monday night football right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here